disons que c'est fondamental le 1er mai
soit un lieu de rassemblement le plus
large pour exprimer les difficultés qui
relève et qu'ils apparaissent durant
tout au long de l'année
au niveau social c'est un organe non
syndical
au fait le choix d'une démarche commune
et je les en félicite
c'est important pour nous que font deux
fois c'était la capitale que ce soit là
que s'expriment que nous exprimons le
ras-le bol que nous vivons en martinique
les gars à la politique sociale la
politique mise en place par les
nouvelles et différents gouvernements
avec la sécurité toute la précarité qui
existe au sein de notre pays en
martinique
aujourd'hui ce qui est important c'est
quoi pour qu'on arrive à recréer ce
rapport de force si nécessaire par
rapport à tout ce qui se décide au
niveau de la france parce que on sait
bien que les dispositions prises de la
france ne sont nullement adapté à notre
réalité martiniquaise et et que les
politiques en martinique ne jouent pas
le jeu c'est ce que nous attendons donc
aujourd'hui le meilleur de l'argot et
pense qu'on pourrait apporter à ces
attaques
c'est de faire l'appoint que nous sommes
en capacité de se mettre tous ensemble
pour du nom à cette politique non à sa
mesure à cette pro d2 de discrimination
il est d'abord glissement de notre
peuple